Je voudrais faire à peu près ce que j'ai fait la première fois,
c'est-à-dire choisir un thème joyeux.
La dernière fois, j'ai parlé de la mort et de la fin de vie.
Cette fois je vais parler de la maladie mentale.
Mais il faut que ce soit technologique,
alors je vais parler d'électrochoc. (Rires)
Depuis que l'homme a eu conscience
que certains dans son entourage, certains de ses confrères,
pouvaient être différents, étranges, sévèrement déprimés
ou ce que nous appelons maintenant schizophrènes,
il était sûr que ce genre de maladie
venait d'esprits malins entrant dans le corps.
Donc la manière de traiter ces troubles
dans les premiers temps consistait, d'une manière ou d'une autre,
à exorciser ces esprits malins, et ça continue, comme vous le savez.
Mais les prêtres ne suffisaient pas.
Quand la médecine est devenue un peu plus scientifique, vers 450 av. J.C.,
avec Hippocrate et les autres,
ils ont essayé de trouver des herbes, des plantes,
qui expulseraient au sens propre les esprits mauvais.
Donc ils ont trouvé des plantes qui pouvaient produire des convulsions.
Et les "Herbiers", les livres de botanique jusqu'à la fin du Moyen Age,
et à la Renaissance, sont remplis de prescriptions
pour produire des convulsions expulsant les esprits malins.
Finalement, vers le 16ème siècle,
un médecin appelé Theophrastus Bombastus Auricularis von Hohenheim,
dit Paracelse, un nom familier à certains ici
-- (Rires) -- ce bon vieux Paracelse,
a découvert qu'il pouvait prédire le degré de convulsion
en utilisant une quantité déterminée de camphre pour produire la convulsion.
Vous vous imaginez aller dans votre placard, prendre une boule de naphtaline
et la mâcher si vous vous sentez déprimé?
C'est mieux que le Prozac, mais je ne le recommanderais pas.
Aux 17ème, 18ème siècles, nous assistons à
la recherche continue d'autres médicaments que le camphre qui feraient l'affaire.
A ce moment vient Benjamin Franklin,
et il en vient presque à se faire convulser
en prenant une décharge électrique avec son cerf-volant.
Et les gens commencent à penser à l'électricité pour produire des convulsions.
Avançons rapidement jusque vers 1932,
lorsque trois psychiatres italiens qui s'occupaient principalement de dépressifs
ont remarqué parmi leurs patients également épileptiques,
que s'ils avaient une crise d'épilepsie -- une série de crises,
plusieurs à la suite -- la dépression disparaissait fréquemment.
Non seulement elle disparaissait, mais elle pouvait ne pas revenir.
Alors ils se sont intéressés à la production de convulsions,
de convulsions mesurables.
Et ils ont pensé "Bon, on a l'électricité, on va brancher quelqu'un à la prise.
Ça fait toujours se dresser les cheveux et trembler beaucoup."
Ils ont donc essayé sur quelques cochons et aucun n'en est mort.
Ils sont ensuite allés voir la police et ils ont dit
"On sait qu'à la gare ferroviaire de Rome,
il y a toutes ces âmes perdues qui errent,
en marmonnant du charabia. Pouvez-vous nous en amener un?"
Quelqu'un qui est, comme disent les italiens, "cagutis."
Donc ils ont trouvé ce "cagutis",
un homme de 39 ans qui était désespérément schizophrène,
qui était connu, depuis des mois,
pour se déféquer dessus,
ne disant rien de sensé,
et ils l'ont amené à l'hôpital.
Ces trois psychiatres, après deux ou trois semaines d'observation,
l'ont étendu sur une table,
ont connecté à ses tempes une petite source de courant.
Ils ont pensé, "Bon, essayons 55 volts, deux dixièmes de seconde.
Ça ne lui fera rien de grave."
Et ils l'ont fait.
Je tiens la suite d'un témoin de première main,
qui me l'a racontée il y a 35 ans,
quand je réfléchissais au sujet
pour un de mes projets de recherche,
il m'a dit, "Ce bonhomme -- n'oubliez pas qu'il n'était pas anesthésié --
après cette importante convulsion,
s'est redressé, a regardé les trois collègues et a dit
'Qu'est-ce que vous foutez, bande de connards?' "
(Rires)
Si seulement je savais le dire en italien.
Ils étaient contents au possible, parce qu'il
n'avait pas dit un mot sensé pendant les semaines d'observation.
Donc ils l'ont branché de nouveau,
cette fois avec du 110 volts pendant une demie seconde.
Et à leur grand étonnement, après que ce fut fini,
il a commencé à parler comme s'il allait parfaitement bien.
Il a un peu rechuté, ils lui ont administré une série de traitements,
et il était à peu près guéri.
Mais bien sûr, étant affecté de schizophrènie,
au bout de quelques mois elle est revenue.
Mais ils ont écrit un article à ce sujet,
et tout le monde occidental s'est mis à utiliser l'électricité
pour faire convulser soit les schizophrènes, soit les dépressifs sévères.
Ça n'a pas très bien marché avec les schizophrènes,
mais il était assez clair dans les années 30 et au milieu des années 40
que la thérapie électroconvulsive était très, très efficace
dans le traitement de la dépression.
Et bien sûr, à cette époque, il n'y avait pas d'antidépresseurs,
et c'est devenu très, très populaire.
Ils anesthésiaient les gens,
les faisaient convulser, mais la vraie difficulté, c'était
qu'il n'y avait pas de moyen de paralyser les muscles.
Alors les gens avaient de vraies convulsions corporelles.
Des os se cassaient -- notamment chez les gens vieux, fragiles,
on ne pouvait pas l'utiliser.
Et puis à la fin des années 50, les relaxants musculaires
ont été mis au point par les pharmacologues,
et on s'est mis à pouvoir induire une convulsion complète,
une convulsion électroencéphalographique -- visible dans les ondes cérébrales --
sans provoquer de convulsion du corps, à part un petit sursaut des orteils.
A nouveau, c'était très très populaire et très très utile.
Bon, et puis au milieu des années 60,
les premiers antidépresseurs sont sortis. Le Tofranil d'abord.
A la fin des années 70, début 80, il y en a eu d'autres,
et ils étaient très efficaces.
Et les groupes de patients semblaient être très mécontents
par certaines choses qu'ils observaient.
Et la thérapie électroconvulsive, par électrochoc, a totalement disparu
-- mais elle a connu une renaissance dans les 10 dernières années.
Et la raison de cette renaissance
tient à ce que probablement près de 10 pour cent des dépressifs sévères
ne réagissent pas, quoi qu'on leur fasse.
Pourquoi est-ce que je vous raconte cette histoire, dans cette conférence?
Je vous la raconte, parce qu'en fait, depuis que
Richard m'a appelé et m'a demandé de parler
-- comme il l'a demandé à tous ses intervenants --
de parler de quelque chose de neuf pour l'auditoire,
dont nous n'avons jamais parlé, rien publié,
j'ai préparé ce moment.
La vraie raison, c'est que je suis un homme dont il y a presque 30 ans,
la vie a été sauvée par deux longues séries de thérapie par électrochoc.
Laissez-moi vous raconter cette histoire.
Dans les années 60, mon mariage était... dire "en mauvais état"
serait peut-être l'euphémisme de l'année.
C'était épouvantable.
Il y a, j'en suis sûr, assez de divorcés dans cette salle
pour comprendre l'hostilité, la colère, et je ne sais quoi d'autre.
Ayant eu une enfance très difficile,
une adolescence très difficile
-- ça avait à voir avec -- pas vraiment la pauvreté mais presque.
Avec avoir été élevé dans une famille où personne ne parlait anglais,
où personne ne lisait ni n'écrivait en anglais.
Avec la mort et la maladie et plein d'autres choses
-- j'étais un peu prédisposé à la dépression.
Donc, à mesure que ça empirait, que nous commencions vraiment à nous haïr,
je suis au fur et à mesure devenu dépressif, en deux ans,
essayant de sauver ce mariage
qui était irrécupérable.
A la fin, je programmais -- toutes mes plus importantes interventions chirurgicales,
je les programmais à midi, une heure de l'après-midi
parce que je ne pouvais pas me lever avant 11 heures.
Et quiconque ici a été déprimé sait ce que c'est.
Je ne pouvais même pas repousser la couverture.
Vous êtes dans le centre hospitalier universitaire,
où tout le monde se connaît, et c'est évident pour mes collègues,
donc le nombre de mes patients a diminué.
A mesure qu'il diminuait,
je suis devenu de plus en plus déprimé
jusqu'à penser, mon Dieu, je ne peux plus travailler.
Et en définitive, ça n'a rien changé
parce que je n'avais plus de patient.
Alors sur le conseil de mon médecin,
j'ai été admis à l'unité de soins intensifs psychiatriques de notre hôpital universitaire.
Et mes collègues, qui me connaissaient depuis la faculté de médecine
à cet endroit, ont dit "Ne t'inquiète pas, gars. Six semaines,
et tu recommences à opérer. Ça va bien se passer."
Vous savez ce que c'est, 'bovine stercus' [bullshit, en pseudo-latin] ?
Ça s'est révélé être un monceau de 'bovine stercus' [conneries].
J'en connais qui ont été titularisés avec des mensonges pareils.
(Rires)
Je fus donc un de leurs échecs.
Mais ce n'était pas si simple. Parce qu'au moment où
j'ai quitté l'unité, je n'étais plus bon à rien.
Je pouvais à peine voir à cinq pieds devant moi.
Je traînais les pieds en marchant. J'étais voûté.
Je me lavais rarement. Parfois je ne me rasais pas. C'était affreux.
Et il était clair -- pas à moi,
parce que rien n'était plus clair pour moi à ce moment-là --
qu'il me faudrait une hospitalisation de longue durée
dans ce lieu atroce qu'on appelle un hôpital psychiatrique.
J'ai été admis en 1973, au printemps 1973,
à l'Institute of Living, qu'on appelait autrefois la Hartford Retreat.
Elle a été fondée au 18ème siècle,
le plus grand hôpital psychiatrique dans l'état du
Connecticut autre que les énormes hôpitaux publics
qui existaient à ce moment-là.
Et ils ont essayé tout ce qu'ils pouvaient.
Ils ont essayé la psychothérapie habituelle.
Ils ont essayé tous les médicaments disponibles à l'époque.
Et ils avaient le Tofranil et d'autres choses -- Mellaril, je ne sais quoi.
Rien ne s'est passé, à part qu'un de ces trucs m'a donné la jaunisse.
Finalement, comme j'étais connu dans le Connecticut,
ils ont décidé qu'ils feraient mieux de réunir les chefs de service.
Les chefs de service se sont réunis, et j'ai découvert plus tard ce qui est arrivé.
Ils se sont tous concertés et ils ont décidé
que rien ne pouvait être fait
pour ce chirurgien qui s'était somme toute séparé du monde,
qui était alors totalement submergé
-- pas seulement par la dépression et des sentiments
d'inutilité et d'insuffisance,
mais par des pensées obsessionnelles,
des pensées obsessionnelles sur les coïncidences.
Il y avait certains nombres, qui quand je les voyais
me bouleversaient terriblement, toutes sortes de rituels --
que des choses atroces, atroces.
Vous vous souvenez quand vous étiez enfant et qu'il fallait marcher sur les lignes?
J'étais un adulte avec tous ces rituels,
et ça a continué jusqu'à une lancinante, une accablante peur dans ma tête.
Vous avez vu cette peinture d'Edvard Munch,
"Le Cri". "Le Cri". Chaque instant était un cri.
Ce n'était pas possible. Alors ils ont décidé qu'il n'y avait pas de thérapie,
qu'il n'y avait pas de traitement. Mais il y avait un traitement,
dans lequel l'hôpital Hartford avait d'ailleurs été pionnier au début des années 40,
Et vous imaginez ce que c'était. C'était la lobotomie pré-frontale.
Alors ils ont décidé -- je n'en savais rien, à nouveau,
je l'ai découvert ensuite --
que la seule chose à faire
à cet homme de 43 ans était une lobotomie
pré-frontale.
Comme dans tous les hôpitaux, il y avait un interne
affecté à mon cas. Il avait 27 ans,
et nous avions rendez-vous deux à trois fois par semaine.
Et bien sûr, j'étais là depuis -- quoi, trois ou quatre mois à ce moment-là.
Et il a demandé à rencontrer les chefs de service, et ils ont accepté
parce qu'il était très bien considéré dans l'hôpital.
Ils lui prédisaient un futur exceptionnel.
Et campant sur ses positions, il a dit,
"Non. Je connais mieux cet homme que vous. Je l'ai rencontré à de nombreuses reprises.
Vous ne l'avez vu que de temps en temps. Vous avez lu des rapports et ainsi de suite.
Je crois vraiment, honnêtement, que le problème de base est seulement la dépression,
et que toutes les pensées obsessionnelles en proviennent.
Et vous savez bien sûr ce qu'il résultera d'une lobotomie pré-frontale.
Toute la gamme de conséquences,
d'assez mauvais à terrible, terrible, terrible
va se produire. S'il va au mieux,
il n'aura plus d'obsessions,
probablement plus de dépression, mais sa vie affective sera terne,
il ne reviendra jamais à la chirurgie,
il ne sera plus le père aimant qu'il a été pour ses deux enfants,
sa vie en sera changée. Si il obtient le résultat habituel,
il finira comme dans "Vol au-dessus d'un nid de coucou."
Vous savez ce que c'est, tout simplement hébété pour le restant de sa vie.
Il a dit "Pourquoi ne pas essayer un traitement par électrochoc?"
Savez-vous pourquoi ils ont accepté? Pour lui faire plaisir.
Ils se sont dits, "Bon, nous allons en faire une série de 10.
Et nous perdrons un peu de temps. La belle affaire. Ça ne change rien."
Donc ils m'en ont donné une série de 10.
Et le premier -- la série habituelle, d'ailleurs, c'était entre six et huit
et c'est toujours entre six et huit --
m'a branché aux fils, m'a endormi, m'a donné un relaxant musculaire.
Six n'ont rien donné. Sept n'ont rien donné.
Huit n'ont rien donné. Au neuvième, j'ai remarqué --
et c'était merveilleux que je puisse remarquer quoi que ce soit
-- j'ai remarqué un changement. Et à 10, j'ai remarqué un vrai changement.
Et il est retourné les voir, et ils ont accepté d'en faire 10 de plus.
A nouveau, pas un seul d'entre eux
-- je pense qu'il étaient environ sept ou huit --
pensait que cela changerait quelque chose. Ils pensaient que le changement n'était que passager.
Mais voilà qu'au seizième, au dix-septième,
il y avait des différences manifestes dans mon état.
Aux 18ème et 19ème, je dormais toute la nuit.
Et au 20ème, j'avais le sentiment, j'avais réellement le sentiment
que je pouvais surmonter ça,
que j'étais à présent assez fort pour que, par un acte de volonté,
je puisse me débarrasser des pensées obsessionnelles,
je puisse me débarrasser de la dépression.
Et je n'ai jamais oublié -- je n'oublierai jamais
-- je me tenais dans la cuisine de l'unité
c'était un dimanche matin de janvier 1973 -- 74 --
je me tenais tout seul dans la cuisine en pensant "j'ai la force de faire ça, maintenant"
C'était comme si ces fils étroitement mêlés dans ma tête avaient été déconnectés
et que je pouvais penser avec clarté.
Mais j'ai besoin d'une formule. J'ai besoin de quelque chose à me dire
quand je me mets à penser de façon obsessionnelle, obsédante.
Les fans de Gilbert et Sullivan [auteurs d'opéras comiques] dans cette salle
se rappelleront Ruddygore et se souviendront de Mad Margaret,
et se souviendront qu'elle était mariée
à un homme nommé Sir Despard Murgatroyd.
Et elle tournait dingue toutes les cinq minutes dans la pièce,
et il lui a dit "Nous devons avoir un mot qui te ramène à la réalité,
et ce mot, ma chère, sera 'Basingstoke'." [Nom d'une ville britannique]
Donc chaque fois qu'elle déraillait un peu,
il disait "Basingstoke!" et elle disait
"Basingstoke, voilà." Et elle allait bien pour un moment.
Vous savez, moi je suis du Bronx. Je ne peux pas dire "Basingstoke".
Mais j'ai trouvé mieux. C'était très simple.
C'était "Et merde!"
(Rires) Bien mieux que "Basingstoke",
au moins pour moi. Et ça a marché, mon Dieu, ça a marché.
Chaque fois que mes pensées devenaient obsessionnelles --
une fois de plus, après 20 électrochocs
-- je disais "Et merde".
Et ça s'améliorait,
et en trois ou quatre mois,
j'étais libéré de cet hôpital et j'ai rejoint un groupe de chirurgiens
où je pouvais travailler avec d'autres personnes,
pas à New Haven, mais juste à côté.
Je suis resté là-bas trois ans.
A la fin des ces trois années, je suis revenu à New Haven,
je m'étais remarié à ce moment-là.
J'ai amené ma femme ici, d'ailleurs, pour être sûr d'arriver à vous parler.
Mes enfants sont revenus vivre avec nous.
Nous avons eu deux autres enfants ensuite.
Ma carrière est repartie, même mieux qu'avant.
J'ai tout de suite repris à l'université
et j'ai commencé à écrire des livres.
Ça a été une vie merveilleuse, vous savez.
Ça a duré, comme j'ai dit, près de 30 ans.
J'ai arrêté d'opérer il y a environ six ans
et je suis devenu écrivain à temps complet, comme beaucoup le savent.
Mais ça a été vraiment passionnant. Ça a été très gai.
De temps en temps, je dois dire "Et merde".
De temps en temps, je suis un peu déprimé, un peu obsessionnel.
Je ne suis pas libéré de tout ça. Mais ça a marché. Ça a toujours marché.
Pourquoi ai-je décidé, alors que je n'en avais jamais parlé, d'en parler maintenant?
Ceux d'entre vous qui connaissent certains de ces livres
savent que l'un concerne la mort et la fin de vie,
un autre le corps et l'esprit humain,
un autre la présence constante de pensées mystiques dans nos esprits,
et ils ont tous à voir avec mes expériences personnelles.
On pourrait penser en lisant ces livres
-- et j'ai des centaines de lettres à leur propos
de gens qui pensent cela --
que vu l'histoire de ma vie comme je l'ai décrite dans ces livres,
l'histoire de ma jeunesse, je suis quelqu'un qui a surmonté l'adversité.
Que je suis quelqu'un qui a bu -- et rebu --
la lie amère du quasi-désastre pendant l'enfance
et en est sorti pas seulement indemne, mais fortifié.
J'ai vraiment tout compris, donc je peux donner des conseils sur
la mort et la fin de vie, je peux parler du mysticisme et de l'esprit humain.
Et je me suis toujours senti coupable de ça.
Je me suis toujours ressenti comme un imposteur, quelque part,
parce que mes lecteurs ne savent pas ce que je viens de vous raconter.
Quelques personnes à New Haven le savent, évidemment,
mais ce n'est pas su de tous.
Donc une des raisons qui m'ont fait venir parler de ça aujourd'hui,
c'est -- franchement, égoïstement --
me libérer d'un fardeau et faire savoir
que ce n'est pas un esprit paisible qui a écrit tous ces livres.
Mais le plus important, je crois,
c'est le fait qu'une proportion significative
de cet auditoire a moins de 30 ans,
et beaucoup, bien sûr, sont bien au-delà de 30 ans.
Pour les moins de 30 ans, il me semble que vous êtes presque tous
-- je dirais tous --
soit à l'orée d'une magnifique et passionnante carrière
soit au coeur d'une magnifique et passionnante carrière ;
tout peut arriver. Les choses changent.
Des accidents, ça arrive. Quelque chose de l'enfance revient vous hanter.
Vous pouvez faire une sortie de piste.
J'espère que ça n'arrivera à aucun de vous,
mais ça arrivera probablement à un petit pourcentage d'entre vous.
Ceux à qui ça n'arrivera pas connaîtront des épreuves.
Si moi, avec la morosité d'esprit,
l'absence d'esprit, que j'avais dans les années 70
et aucun espoir de guérison,
selon ce groupe de psychiatres chevronnés,
si je peux me sortir de ça,
croyez-moi, n'importe qui peut se sortir
de n'importe quelle épreuve dans sa vie.
Et pour les plus vieux, qui ont traversé
peut-être pas quelque chose d'aussi dur que ça
mais qui ont eu des moments difficiles,
qui y ont peut-être tout perdu, comme moi,
et ont tout recommencé à nouveau, certaines de ces choses leur seront familières.
La guérison existe.
La rédemption existe. Et la résurrection existe.
La thématique de la résurrection se retrouve dans toutes les sociétés connues,
et ça pas seulement parce que nous fantasmons
la possibilité de la résurrection et de la guérison,
mais parce que ça arrive vraiment. Ça arrive souvent.
L'histoire de résurrection la plus populaire sans doute,
en dehors de celles proprement religieuses,
est celle du phénix, l'ancienne histoire du phénix
qui, tous les 500 ans, renaît de ses cendres
pour aller vivre une vie qui est
encore plus belle qu'avant. Richard,
merci beaucoup.